Canadian transgender athlete is facing a
backlash after winning the cycling World
Championship Rachel McKinnon who was
born male finished first in the race in
Los Angeles this Sunday becoming the
first ever transgender woman to win gold
in the competition but her achievement
was met not only with applause unfair
advantage and not to be celebrated look
at the difference in size and muscle
mass of course you were going to win
imagine being the woman who came forth
knowing that you should have a place on
that podium amazing
I was so enthused at reading this I went
out and challenged to eight-year-olds to
a 100-meter race guess what I only went
in one first time running in an
eight-year-olds race - the winner denies
the accusation saying she was forced to
suppress her testosterone level in
accordance with competition rules on
transgender athletes so we invited some
guests for a debate what I find strange
is the hue and cry being raised over
transgender athletes but not over other
athletes who clearly have certain
advantages over fellow competitors I
think the way in which transgender
athletes are being singled out is very
very unfair and wrong now of course we
do need to look at whether transgender
athletes do have an advantage which is
unfair and gives them an advantage over
others but I don't think the research
really substantiate that at the moment
female athletes themselves fear feel
that there are some particular
disadvantage in competing against
somebody whose gender has been in some
cases changed you know the happing cases
in the past I mean the most celebrated
case was of a American tennis player
really Richards who as a man was a
useful player captain the Yale team and
then underwent transgender reassignment
and competed as a woman and reached the
final of the doubles of the US Open
tennis championships you know one of the
four Grand Slams are the most important
in the world and as a singles player
ended up ranked 20th and this was at the
age of 44 when she reached that level
and you would look at that case and say
well would really riches as a man ever
been able to have reached those sorts of
heights as a man and that is of course
extremely doubtful there are all kinds
of advantages that athletes have for
sprinters having fast twitch muscle
fibers definitely gives you an advantage
it isn't just this issue it's it's a
whole range of issues about where
genetic and other biological factors may
give a particular athlete the edge over
others I certainly think there should be
as far as transgender and intersex
situations are concerned going further
than that I think would be a an enormous
task of just quite gargantuan
proportions hopefully there would be
some kind of consensus and we could
establish a regime for all sports we're
particularly athletes who are
transgender and intersex but also those
who perhaps have other special unique
physical attributes or biological or
genetic attributes that they could be
included
you